[Music]
anyhoo your pals what was that all about
you were just here then they had
originally went yes he had said you'd
know when I came out yeah what did I
rewrite this way
that's your Yiddish fanclub that's right
fantastic yeah ladies that's right
they're here for Andy any growl Adam
come on ladies
oh that's more frankincense ah now
you're frightened man
this shows broken already welcome to the
program we have a great program for you
tonight yes speaking of big
entertainment big movie right now is the
Hobbit hobbits are right now back today
what was the The Hobbit came out last
week and it's the story of a small man
wandering around with a ring that's
right it's about Tom Cruise's search for
a new wife
[Applause]
that's saying I do everytime after a
zinger now he's got the zinger
convulsions yeah it's true though the
The Hobbit came out on Friday some
critics are saying it's too long yeah
yeah in fact one critic was so angry he
walked out only two days into the film
[Music]
you know was having a great holiday
season Andy besides us there's nice and
sear bone in your body
there's one
[Applause]
and we are never getting through the
show I'll take who's having a great
holiday season Apple Apple's having a
great holiday season check this out just
three days after its launch Apple sold
more than two million iPhone 5s in China
can you imagine that yeah two million in
China so even in China the best gifts
are always the ones your kids make
[Applause]
that was please over the weekend two men
you probably heard about this was a
picture and everything two men got
engaged at the White House yeah so I
guess the talks between Obama and
Boehner going better than expected
over the weekend a man was arrested
trying to break into Taylor Swift's
house yeah that's a good thing police
arrived because if there's one thing we
know Taylor's not good at its holding on
to a man
[Applause]
I'm singing left and I'm singing right
what just just keep doing this yeah yeah
sure yeah okay I heard one girl that
time last month many residents of Denver
Colorado claim they saw a UFO in the sky
you believe that
yeah just keep in mind last month
Colorado voted to legalize marijuana
[Music]
[Applause]
I saw a UFO in there and he's sure the
hacker remember this guy the hacker who
leaked nude pictures of Scarlett
Johansson was sentenced to 10 years yeah
ten years of Awesomeness
there's no time to high-five all of you
[Music]
it just came out that the McRib sandwich
is not actually made from rib meat and
in fact the mcribs original name was the
mixed stuff that didn't make it into the
McNugget we're done there's some stuff
left over and then